honestly i'm totally loss of words
totally lost for words what's happened
the past week the past couple of days
you know just
yeah the emotions are all even more so
you went over when i wrote the tweet on
saturday it was it was as certain
between it's my bang anniversary it was
my anniversary again blowing up as us
scotty's called it your bang anniversary
so that day's always raw for me anyway
raw for me and my family normally i'm
i'm quite quiet i uh keep myself to
myself you know i mean my wife will have
a few drinks and
reminisce but i just felt on saturday i
had to write something i had to put my
two pence and just seeing events unfolds
in afghanistan just heartbreaking and
devastating to see just the country i
fought in and fought for
has just just gone up in smoke like that
absolutely crazy
jack that's the thing you say you keep
yourself
to yourself you've just got on with life
because you felt like you made a
sacrifice
for the future of afghanistan and its
people
and i wonder what you feel thinking
about them now i mean
the desperation of those people on the
tarmac and they're the ones that can
make it to the airport there are many in
provinces that have no access no way out
and i just wonder
what you think about them because you
had to leave them behind but you thought
you were leaving them in safe hands
absolutely i just feel so sorry for them
um
um you know i'm saying my best wishes
the 600 powers that have gone out and i
you know i hope they all come home safe
and sound and they bring home
as many as possible including as many
interpreters as they can get hold of you
know if anybody deserves the right to be
free and and live in peace and come to
the uk as the interpreters that helped
western forces and i i really hope they
can get as many as possible i feel sorry
for the country of afghanistan um
you know my job out there was to find
bombs to find night improvised explosive
devices i love my job i i'm so proud to
have served in the british military in
the british army and the job i'd done
was high risk but i loved it it's high
adrenaline i had a bad day at the office
as i i joke about and you know i squad
of humor squad bands you got a life you
don't laugh you cry but just seeing
just involved the past week watching
your new show and other news programs
just the devastation the loss just how
easy the taliban have taken over the
country it's just
i'm just lost for words
jack do you think allied forces should
have stayed the u.s president joe biden
his final withdrawal of u.s troops was
seen as the the final straw giving the
taliban a green light to move in and
they took over the country in less than
two weeks that caught everyone off guard
it seems including the united states
do you think a presence should have
remained because the excuse that
president biden used was
we don't want a forever war
i i get that to a degree i truly do and
i'm not naive i knew we couldn't stay
here forever afghanistan and afghans got
the right to look after themselves and
govern themselves and to look after
themselves us being british soldiers we
trained up the afghans the afghan
national army you know you know the
british army is the best in the world
and we gave them the best training the
best weapons spent god knows how many
millions training them
and
i get it we couldn't have stayed there
but just to see
the quick withdrawal and then it to go
up and smoke in a week or whatever it
was it just just doesn't feel right and
it that can't be right and you know
i got no answer you know the the the
call or some way above my pay raise it
was the course from the president the
united states of america and the pm it
was nothing to do with me i'm
as i said in my tweet i fought my war my
fight is done i'm home and i'm positive
i'm lucky to be alive and i'm very
thankful to being live i'm i'm making
the most of my life you know i just
wanted to put my two pence and just put
in my opinion that's all it was
jack your opinion counts you were there
you paid a sacrifice
to keep afghanistan and its people safe
and that has all been undone so you are
more than welcome to to give us your two
pennies worth one pound five however
much you want on this show
i just wonder what you would say to
boris johnson if he's watching now
because the defense secretary was on sky
news earlier today and said there is no
option of uk troops going back that part
of the war in afghanistan is done
sure
to boris johnson
me personally was it worth it
you know he said you know british
soldiers didn't die in vain but i don't
think he'll ever say that face to face
of a grieving mum or a grieving wife a
grieving father
[Music]
you know i lost my legs and i will never
walk again and i'm bound to a wheelchair
for rest my life don't get me wrong i
knew the rest i i signed up on the
deadline and i knew the risk going out i
was proud to serve my country i knew
that but i wanted something out of
afghanistan i truly felt i was making a
difference in afghanistan every bomb
that i was finding was saying their life
these bombs don't discriminate these
ideas don't discriminate it doesn't
matter if you're a british serviceman
american or your your local afghan if
you stand then it's going bang and
you're you're losing a leg you're losing
alarm you're losing your life everyone i
found was hoping to make a difference
just seeing the taliban just just walk
around and got their own detail and it's
filling their own boots it's it's
it's it's horrendous and uh yeah i
honestly when they were on saturday to
the prime minister